[Music]
hey guys if you have watched the trailer
of jurassic world dominion then you
would have been a little bit shocked at
the size of one big dinosaur that came
out at the end
it was seen in the ending scenes of the
trailer and dr ian malcolm stated
do they always have to go bigger
in this clip we see a huge gigantosaurus
probably cloned from the same one seen
in the prologue
as to how they got the samples well
that will also be explained in detail in
this video but the main topic is to
assess the probable size of the
giganotosaurus that will appear in the
movie so subscribe if you haven't
already and now let's get to it
now let's start with the giganotosaurus
from real life and to start with the
topic let's dive into the past this
species is a part of a genus of theropod
dinosaur that lived in what is now
argentina during the early cinemanian
age of the late cretaceous period
approximately 99.6 to 97 million years
ago the dragonotosaurus was one of the
largest known terrestrial carnivores but
the exact size has been hard to
determine
due to the incompleteness of the remains
found so far
estimates for the most complete specimen
range from a length of 12 to 13 meters
or 39 to 43 feet long
a skull of 1.5 to 1.8 meters or 5 to 6
feet in length and a weight of 4.2 to
13.8 tons
so it would be somewhere in the same
size range as the largest specimen of a
t-rex which is sue and she is 12 meters
or 40 feet long and was 4 meters or 13
feet tall at the hips
now let's shift to the giganotosaurus
from the prologue well although the
giganotosaurus was seen fighting a
feathered t-rex in the prologue this
shouldn't have really happened or have
been possible since they existed 30
million years apart if this
giganotosaurus species did exist then it
would have not been the same as the ones
in the fossil records it would have been
a further evolved species of the dragon
thesaurus lineage and it could probably
be true since the past is full of
secrets and mysteries and we know only
less than one percent of the dinos that
ever existed never mind the ones that
co-existed in the same time frame
so it could be possible that there is
yet another apex predator larger than
the t-rex during the same timeline but
we haven't discovered yet just like the
apex predators the tigers the bengal
tigers and the asiatic lions in the
indian subcontinent go existing together
so regarding the giganotosaurus vs
tyrannosaurus rex fight this shouldn't
have really taken place but with our
presumption of an undiscovered species
it might have been a common occurrence
in the prehistoric times if two large
carnivores did inhabit the same niche
so the fight was a quick one we hope
that there will be an extended scene of
the battle in the movie so as to give
the chance for the t-rex to prove itself
and not look like a weakling well in the
battle the giganotosaurus completely
overpowered the wrecks in a measly
20-second duel and it killed it by
snapping its neck but this did serve as
the genesis of the entire modern
timeline where the mosquito carrying the
rexy's dna was discovered and jurassic
park was created
so going to the main topic at hand the
giganotosaurus size estimation
in the prologue we see both the jagger
and the t-rex having a similar body size
but the former was a bit bigger and a
bit bulkier and taller than the
feathered rex who although big wasn't up
to the mark in terms of size the
jagger's head towered over the wrecks
when they were intimidating each other
and when they were face to face we could
clearly see that the jagger's head was
slightly longer than the rex's even
though it was
less bulkier
it was longer more heavily armored with
crocodilian skin
has scales as well and small spikes on
its back and a heavier built tail so
when all of this put together we can
clearly say that the prehistoric jagger
was indeed larger than the rex
that it fought but since we don't really
know the maturity of the t-rex there we
can't really come to a size estimation
so what about the trailers
giganotosaurus size well we can
definitely say now that they have
extracted the dna and clone one specimen
of the fallen kingdom
so let's go back again to the words of
ian malcolm
do they always have to go bigger
by that statement and the fact that
malcolm had seen both rexy and the two
big t-rexes of isla sauna in the second
movie he would know what he was talking
about the jagger will definitely be
bigger than the t-rex even in modern
times and it was confirmed to be the
biggest connoisseur ever so its length
would definitely be close to 50 feet
and a height of 18 to 20 feet tall given
the fact that rexy is 43 feet long and
16 feet tall
but is it really bigger than the
spinosaurus is it the biggest ever
well in both reveals of these two
dinosaurs there were comments on them
being bigger than the t-rex
if you remember in jurassic park 3 alan
grant stated that the roar that came
from something bigger than a t-rex
[Music]
or at least it was it sounds bigger and
it indeed was the spinosaurus was around
49 feet long and was close to 20 feet
tall due to its sail on his back but the
jagger on the other hand doesn't have a
sail and again since ian malcolm said
do they always have to go bigger
it means that either this new entry
would at least be as big as the spinal
and a fully grown indominus rex or
possibly be even bigger since yet again
this would be of a yet undiscovered
species that existed alongside the t-rex
30 million years after the holotype
specimen of the real-life [ __ ] was
dated to
so now another question is how did they
get the samples
as for the majority of the extinct
creatures brought back to life by
cloning the dinosaurs at least the dna
samples were extracted from mosquitoes
stuck in fossilized resin called amber
the same mosquito that bit the dead
t-rex in the prologue could have flown
to the jagger on the same day and bit it
and suck its blood and then get itself
stuck in amber
in a stomach content would be the dna of
two giant predatory dinosaurs
it wouldn't have been a recent discovery
since uh indian ass of 2014 did have the
dna sequence of the giganotosaurus and
used it alongside with that of the t-rex
the raptors and other modern species to
give rise to the hybrid that is the
indominus rex
now the last question
why was it created with the events of
fallen kingdom and dr henry wu's
apparent outside the company policy act
of creating hybrids he might have
alongside other members of engine
abandoned the company and worked for a
rival group that was confirmed to appear
in dominion and that is biosin yet
another genetics company hellbent on
creating dinos a bigger dinosaur with
more teeth would have fetched a lot of
money and with rumors that they would
have some sort of mind control for using
the creatures as bio weapons
then the jaguar thesaurus would be a
tank in the arsenal of this antagonistic
group
the jagger is a mystery to us all
and yes alongside the atrocioraptors and
even the quetzalcoatlus these dinos
would be prized possession of private
military contractors and even the u.s
military
so that they would be used as weapons
and the people behind it would have
plausible deniability but that's just my
take
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and with that we come to the end
of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind kio family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam